okay this will be not tutorial how to
record higher quality videos in
camstudio whether it's high quality or
high didn't this is how I do it first of
all you need cams video in the first
place so open up your internet browser
whether it be Firefox Safari Opera
Explorer flock whatever type in um dip
first thing is wow what am I thinking
mmm first you need camstudio it's free
screen recording software it's freeware
so no need to torrent or anything it's
at camstudio dork why is it taking so
long and this is what it looks like you
know free streaming video software
scroll about halfway down the page and
you will download it okay so you
downloaded extract etc very simple
instructions once you're done with
downloaded camstudio and you know you
run it and you get this box I'm getting
high quality because I went to vidiians
first of all and use the DivX six point
eight point five codec which uses both
your CPUs um a bit on 100% quality and I
click auto adjust and drag this so that
it says 30 frames per second right you
know sometimes gets a little bit off but
okay cuz I'm whatever it's YouTube so to
get this DivX codec you're not going to
have when you first download CCleaner so
open your internet browser and download
and install give DivX codec it'll be the
flink when you google DivX get comm
click on it it's kind of a flashy
website
um
all right when that is done you want to
download and install the DivX codec it
will try to install about a hundred
Meg's of software on your computer but
you only need the DivX codec which is
about seven or about ten so you have the
DivX codec and ian's click on it
detector 130 like I said figure this is
where you set it to the 720 profile 720
HD profile which will give you higher
quality on YouTube I didn't change
anything so go to file of - that is
advanced you can make difficult
files/default stuff whatever I leave
this all the way to this 3000 kilobits
per second and I hit OK and also for
region if you click fixed region which
is what I have one right now you will
have the choice to set your resolution
or the adjust the size of it so I have
at explode by 360 you can do a number of
resolutions which I will I think I wrote
it down hold on here we go so you can
have it in any of these resolutions so
just pause the video and take a look at
it
there you go so set it to one of those
and you don't have your entire screen
resolution mine is only 640 by 360 then
you want to hit it you want to enable
auto pan so that it follows your mouse
wherever goes along the screen simple
but it'll give you HD quality video or
high quality thanks for watching
you